the best answer if you are just starting
is always going to be quantity and not
quality here's why if you are truly just
starting on YouTube chances are you may
not even fully know what you want to
talk about yet you don't have any camera
skills you haven't really figured out
your voice you don't have much
experience creating content now to argue
this point you could point to a Creator
who starts a brand new channel and from
day one they're bringing a high level of
quality but I would argue they probably
have previous experience elsewhere maybe
they've had another Channel maybe
they've had an acting career maybe they
have a media company backing them a lot
of times if you start with quality you
actually aren't starting from zero but
assuming you are starting from zero and
video is new to you and YouTube is new
to you quantity is absolutely the best
strategy for phase one this gives you
two things it gives you practice and it
gives you feedback from the audience
many people have heard the story of Mr
Beast who talks about how he uploaded
two 200 terrible videos before he
started to get real momentum on YouTube
if you look at the gaming Creator
PewDiePie he uploaded hundreds of videos
before he started to get momentum and
when you ask either of those creators
how they feel about their first videos
they would tell you the video sucked
they were terrible they were really bad
but I was getting practice I was getting
experience I was learning the process of
creating videos and I was learning the
skills necessary for being a content
creator so in Phase One quantity is
better than quality because the more
reps you can put in the quicker you can
develop your skills two things number
one I've had too much coffee today
number two if you have not seen our free
master class yet you're gonna love it if
you're serious about growing your
YouTube channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class